er sitzt bereits hinter eingeblendet und
zwar geht es heute mal wieder um april
derartige der noch beschissener ist als
alle scheiße auf dieser welt zusammen
ich möchte das heutige video in drei
abschnitte unterteilen und zwar erstens
worum geht es eigentlich beim artikel 13
und warum sind so viele dagegen zweitens
was sind die neuesten entwicklungen und
drittens wie sollte man sich jetzt
verhalten also fangen wir direkt an mit
punkt nummer eins worum geht es
eigentlich bei artikel 13 falls ist
tatsächlich noch jemand nicht
mitbekommen haben sollte der titel 13
bzw
in der jetzigen form betitelte artikel
17 ist teil einer neuen
urheberrechtsreform axel voss ist
berichterstatter des europäischen
parlaments für diese neue richtlinie und
nebenbei auch noch meist gehasste person
im internet mit gras gegen allerdings
zurück zur urheberrechts reformen uns
war denkt sich vielleicht der eine oder
andere zuschauer gerade
urheberrechtsreform die besteht
vielleicht aus 13 artikeln artikel 13
ist blöd und der ist dann auch seite 5
ganz am ende der urheberrechtsreform es
über 500 seiten lang also das ist ein
ordentlicher fladen aber was sind denn
eigentlich die ziele dieser reform
anpassung an die neue realität also das
von angela merkel betitelt neuland
internet rechteinhaber müssen besser
geschützt werden und die zersplitterung
des urheberrechts in den
mitgliedsstaaten muss verhindert werden
das hört sich ja eigentlich ziemlich gut
an aber was genau gesagt denn jetzt
diese artikel 13 zählweise sind werden
diese artikel besagt zusammengefasst
kommerzielle websites und apps wo nutzer
beiträge veröffentlichen können müssen
bestmögliche anstrengungen unternehmen
vorab lizenzen für alles zu haben was
ihre nutzer möglicherweise posten
könnten also alle inhalt
der welt die unter das urheberrecht
fallen müssen lizenziert werden
das ist unmöglich zusätzlich müssen die
webseiten alles in ihrer macht stehende
tun um alle inhalte im vornherein zu
blockieren bei denen es sich eventuell
um unerlaubte kopien handeln könnte bei
den datenmengen die sekündlich
hochgeladen werden geht das nur mit
upload filtern und sollte dann ein
gericht jedoch feststellen dass eine
website nicht alles zur lizensierung
beziehungsweise filterung unternommen
hat wird die website direkt für die
urheberrechtsverletzungen ihrer nutzer
haftbar gemacht also so als hätte die
website selbst die
urheberrechtsverletzung begangen und
diese drogen würde dann in folge dessen
dazu führen dass die websiten
overclocking betreiben würden also sie
würden schlichtweg erstmal alle sperren
was auch nur ansatzweise eine
klitzekleine urheberrechtsverletzung
beinhalten können
das wäre dann die vorstufe einer zensur
geil europäisches parlament versteht
mich aber bitte nicht falsch ich bin
keineswegs gegen ein neues
urheberrechtsgesetze hierbei müssen
besser vergütet werden und ihre werke
müssen besser geschützt werden
allerdings war es von anfang an nicht
die intention hinter artikel 11 artikel
13 artikel sitz in die bestehenden
probleme im urheberrecht zu lösen
sondern die einzige intention war es die
taschen von lobby starken branchen zu
füllen die egal mit welchen
nebenwirkungen alle möglichen experten
menschenrechts handy-os unabhängige
verlage start-ups internetpioniere und
auch 200 protestierende menschen und 5
millionen menschen eine petition
unterschrieben haben haben sich klar
gegen diesen artikel 13 beziehungsweise
17 ausgesprochen jedoch hat die cdu csu
oder einfach alles ignoriert und dann
auch noch die menschen die auf die
straße gegangen sind die familienpartei
laut der union wurden alle mehr als
200.000 demonstrierenden menschen
gekauft und den großen konzernen google
etc
wie soll angeblich pro person 450 euro
bekommen haben google dann kommt mein
geld an zuvor wurde bei the way von der
cdu/csu auch einfach behauptet dass alle
mails die sie bekommen haben von uns
besorgten bürgern dass wir einfach von
bots gespendet wurden ich habe uns
einfach unsere menschlichkeit genommen
von daher war der protest gar nicht mehr
allein gegen diese zensur maschine
artikel 13 gerichtet sondern auch gegen
die ignoranten und arroganten politiker
der cdu/csu
also mal ganz kurz der erste punkt
zusammengefasst beim artikel 13 geht es
um die neue urheberrechtsreform und die
ist wirklich dringend nötig also wir
müssen besser geschützt werden
allerdings ist der jetzige entwurf hat
schlichtweg scheiße und stärkt keine
urheber sondern lediglich große
verlagshäuser wie axel springer oder die
autoren gesellschaft geber und da das
ganze im eu parlament durchgewunken
wurde erleben wir in zwei jahren eine
drastische veränderung des internets und
eventuell die vorstufe einer zensuren
wenn das logging so kommen sollte wie es
einige experten beziehungsweise kritiker
vermuten dann werden 99 prozent von uns
wahrscheinlich strich werk erstmal gar
nichts hochladen können profitieren wird
davon also schlichtweg am ende niemand
außer die großen verlagshäuser und
gesellschaften und axel springer ganz
vorne mit dabei
hier sieht man friede springer mit
angela merkel also da weiß man schon was
abgeht und wem unsere kanzlerin wirklich
dient ja darum geht's bei artikel 13
deswegen sind viele dagegen und jetzt
kommen wir zu punkt 2 dieses videos was
sind die neuesten entwicklungen im eu
parlament wurde ja pro
urheberrechtsreform abgestimmt von daher
wird sie definitiv kommen und so der
abstimmung im eu parlament und dem
ergebnis habe ich ja bereits vor 12
wochen hier schon ein video auf einem
kanal hochgeladen jedoch ist in der
zwischenzeit nun wieder einiges passiert
die spd die bei der abstimmung im eu
parlament zumindest nahezu geschlossen
gegen die reform war hat uns komplett
verarscht ganz kurz im koalitionsvertrag
zwischen der union also cdu csu und der
spd steht upload filter werden
bis mäßig abgelehnt viele menschen und
auch ich haben sich dann auf die
vernunft der spd verlassen im gegensatz
zu der ignoranten und verlogenen cdu/csu
und wir haben uns dann einfach gedacht
hey
die spd müsste doch einfach nur sagen
wir berufen uns auf den
koalitionsvertrag denn hier haben wir
festgehalten dass wir ab laut filter
ablehnen also müssen wir uns auch daran
halten jedoch hat sich nun bei einer von
der linken organisierten debatte im
bundestag gestern in artikel 13 gezeigt
dass die spd schlichtweg keine eier hat
so was auch nur ansatzweise bei der
cdu/csu anzumerken und die spd hat sich
sogar nicht einfach nur enthalten bei
der debatte gestern sondern die haben
die richtlinie mit samen artikel 13 mit
silvester tinkl 17 auch noch schön
geredet und gesagt hey das ist super das
muss kommen damit menschen nicht gesund
ziemlich abstoßen das hat sich nun also
auch bei dieser sache wieder mal gezeigt
dass die spd einfach nur das kleine
schoßhündchen der cdu csu sondern uns
alle verarscht hat uns alle angelogen
hat und das komplette internet
hintergangen hat danke dafür an der
stelle bezüglich der spd muss man
allerdings auch noch sagen dass timo
welchen wirklich sehr gute arbeit
geleistet hat und auch gegen diese
richtlinie war also nicht jeder der spd
ist schlichtweg gehört dass man so dumm
zu sagen allerdings besteht die partei
hat leider nicht nur aus timo werken wer
hat uns verraten sozialdemokraten also
den demo spruch von den artikel 13 d
muss kann man nun auch wieder singen ja
was ist noch so passiert die gema hat
aufgrund von urheberrechtsverletzungen
die website boerse.de für rund 25
millionen deutsche vodafone und 1&1
kunden sperren lassen da er die aussage
des switch gründen das image dass alle
eu user auf der plattform twitter
gesperrt werden wurde dementiert achso
und unsere justizministerin katharina ba
lady immer vor uns wlan so war hey ich
bin gegen artikel 13 hat jetzt auch noch
werbung für die reform gemacht und wird
der reform jetzt auch noch zustimmen
ich finde es einfach nur krass wie
politiker und ganze parteien sind so
ekelhaft
viele millionen menschen direkt in die
fresse lügen können
nicht in der lage wenn ich jemanden
haben kommen wir allerdings nun zum
letzten finalen punkt 3 wie sollte man
sich jetzt verhalten erstens und das ist
das allerwichtigste geht weiterhin auf
die demos morgen sind wieder viele demos
in großen deutschen städten und unter
anderem auch hier bei uns in köln wieder
um 11 uhr 30 am roncalliplatz geht dort
auf jeden fall hin seit laut und setzt
euch für eure rechte ein denn nur so
hört uns die politik und das zweite was
ebenfalls ganz ganz ganz ganz wichtig
ist ist dass ihr wählen geht sofern ihr
dürft und sonst bitte eure eltern und
großeltern informieren am 23 bis zum 26
mai ist die europawahl und so nur mal
zur info sah die abstimmung im september
2018 aus den konservativen hier gilt
übrigens axel voss an nur mal so zur
info und so haben sich die deutschen
abgeordneten im europaparlament nun ende
märz vor ein paar tagen entschieden man
sieht also ganz klar dass die cdu/csu
nahezu komplett dafür war und alle
anderen parteien nahezu komplett dagegen
die spd muss man hier allerdings auch
sagen dass sie zwar im europa parlament
dagegen gestimmt haben nun in
deutschland allerdings wieder das
schoßhündchen von der cdu csu sind keine
eier die ist das habe ich ja schon
gesagt also ich würde mir bei den wahlen
wirklich 20 mal überlegen ob ich der
cdu/csu bzw der spd meine stimme geben
würde nicht nur wegen dieser
entscheidungen hinsichtlich der
urheberrechtsreform unseren allgemein
sie uns alle angelogen haben die letzten
wochen und allgemeinen noch wegen den
diffamierungen den beleidigungen den
antrieben geht's also die liste ist
wirklich lange warum man die eigentlich
eher nicht wählen sollte da ich
unfassbar viele kommentare und
nachrichten von euch bekommen und
gelesen habe nach dem motto hey luca wen
willst du denn wählen möchte ich jetzt
ganz offen sagen ich will die fdp weil
ich bin ganz ehrlich die rede im
bundestag gestern hat mich auch nochmal
wieder überzeugt werfen ihr auch vor
dass in der die infrage digitalisierung
komplett untätig bleiben aber finde ich
mir
sein parteifreund und europa bord in
sachsen frost angucke dann würde ich mir
wissen sie bleiben um die allgemeine
einstellung und das parteiprogramm der
fdp sagt mir persönlich zumindest am
meisten zu jedoch möchte ich euch hier
keineswegs manipulieren welche partei er
wählen soll und daher findet ihr unten
in der beschreibung ganz ganz ganz ganz
viele links zu wahl infos
parteiprogrammen und beispielsweise auf
dem warum also das ist so ein quiz mehr
oder weniger und da kann man dann fragen
beantworten und dann sagt einem die
website den man am ehesten wählen sollte
der wahlomat für die europawahl
allerdings wird erst am dritten mai
veröffentlicht also rund drei wochen vor
der europawahl und abschließend möchte
ich jetzt einfach noch mal zu diesem
ganzen thema sagen danke an euch für
euren riesigen support bei der petition
wir haben über fünf millionen
unterschriften bei den demos waren
hunderttausende und auch allgemein wie
viel ihr haben die abgeordneten
geschrieben habe wie viele von euch die
angerufen haben und auch wenn der
artikel 13 bzw jetzt genannte artikel 17
final wirklich kommen wird haben wir
denn noch alles in unserer macht
stehende getan und werden auch noch
weiterhin alles in unserer macht
stehende dafür tun dass er nicht so
radikal mit upload filtern und dieser
zensur maschine kommen wir jetzt von
einigen politikern und parteien
angedacht wird das was wir bisher
gemacht haben war definitiv nicht
umsonst die politiker wissen nun dass
wir existieren und sie wissen dass wir
laut sind und sie wissen dass wir enorm
viele sind also geht auf jeden fall
weiter auf die straße setzt euch ein für
eure interessen und in der video
beschreibung ist ein link für die demos
morgen und was ich auch noch mal eben
kurz sagen wollte ist dass sich diese
videos nicht mache werde ich
irgendwelche existenzängste haben oder
angst hätte dass ich keine videos mehr
machen kann ich soll laut meinung
einiger so wie viele andere große
youtuber auch von dieser richtlinie
eigentlich profitieren
aber darum geht es nicht sondern es gibt
vielmehr darum dass demnächst alles
gefiltert wird also wenn ich ihnen die
zitate unter dem bild schreibe dann wird
es wahrscheinlich nicht kommen wenn ich
irgendein foto allgemein hochladen dann
wird es entweder dauern bis es
veröffentlicht wird oder einfach durch
das abblocken überhaupt nicht gepostet
weil
eventuell eine urheberrechtsverletzung
sein könnte wenn ihr auf einem konzert
seit von beispielsweise schon mendes und
dem film was unsere instagram story pack
und hab eigentlich keine bösen absichten
jetzt erst mal geblockt und keiner sieht
euer konzern die liste ist so unfassbar
lang was sich alles wahrscheinlich
verändern wird wenn es so durchkommt wie
es jetzt gerade im gesetzestext steht
also kurzum das internet so wie wir es
gerade kennen und lieben wird sich
komplett grundsätzlich verändern und
erich und ich glaube auch wir alle das
so nicht wollen dass das internet sich
so grundlegend verändert mache ich auch
gerne auch noch ein viertes video dazu
unten 5600 ist ich glaube wir haben alle
kein bock dass erst die vorstufe einer
zensur kommt durch die upload filter und
dann eine komplett regulierte zensur
also check gern die infobox apfel
weitere informationen bezüglich demos
und wahl infos et cetera und ich wir als
pizza fressen
[Musik]